>> ERIC: Hi. My name is Eric and I work on
Android. I'm here to tell you about some cool
features of the Android 1.5 release. One of
the main additions we've introduced in this
update is the virtual keyboard. It has a bunch
of cool features. You can set it up so that
as you type, it gives you tactile feedback
by vibrating the screen. A pretty handy trick
if you're not used to typing on the touch
screen. It also gives suggestions and autocorrects
your spelling so that you can type quickly
and easily. The virtual keyboard works in
any application: Gmail, the browser, SMS,
and even third party apps. But what's also
nice is that apps have the ability to flip
between landscape and portrait mode. So the
virtual keyboard is great. But if you don't
feel like typing or if you're searching for
a long or a hard to spell phrase, you can
simply say your search using search by voice.
Another new set of features we've added to
Android includes video recording, playback,
and sharing. Recording a video is really straightforward,
simply point and shoot. Say "hi," Jim.
>> JIM: Hi.
>> ERIC: Sharing videos with friends couldn't
be easier. Simply click "Share" and choose
how to share it. You can e-mail, SMS, or even
upload directly to YouTube. Jim, you and your
funny hat are about to get famous. And while
the upload happens in the background, you
can continue using the phone as usual: make
a call, text, or even record and upload a
new video. Another cool feature is the ability
to customize your phone with home screen widgets
that provide immediate access to valuable
information and applications. The phone comes
preloaded with great widgets like calendar,
a music player and Google Search. We're really
excited to see what new widgets developers
come up with next. You can find these new
widgets and of course great applications in
Android Market. For more information on Android
and the Android 1.5 release, please visit
android.com.